learn how to pay attention to what matters to your employees
being a female leader or being a leader really
I thought it was fascinating
I mean let's be honest
and I thought it was a fantastic question
learn to understand who your employees are
so whether you're a male or a female the best way to be a great leader
great leaders listen to their teams
and they're all about developing people
learn how to actively listen
not who you think they are but who are they really
they pay attention to what matters
they don't sweat the small stuff
for the most part
they said how do I go from being a great female leader to just a great leader
the characteristics of a great leader fit male or female are the same
leaders develop leaders
I had someone ask me this question